[Música]
México vivió un terremoto de magnitud
7,7 que causó pánico y deja al menos una
persona fallecida el sismo que tuvo
epicentro en el Estado de Michoacán se
registró justo en el aniversario de los
terremotos de 1985 y 2017 considerados
los dos más destructivos en la historia
reciente del país
la cifra de arrestos de indocumentados
en la frontera sur de Estados Unidos
alcanza un nuevo récord por primera vez
se superaron los dos millones de
detenciones esto en los últimos 11 meses
al tiempo que se conoció que el número
de detenciones de venezolanos cubanos y
nicaragüenses ha aumentado
considerablemente ampliamos desde
Washington
la agencia espacial de Brasil informó
que la cifra de incendios registrados en
la amazonía brasileña ya superó el total
de 2021 el monitoreo por satélite
muestra que en lo que va del año se han
presentado casi
75.600 con flagraciones lo que suma a la
presión sobre el presidente Jair
bolsonaro que se presenta a la
reelección en octubre
Bienvenidos a esta misión con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
México porque un terremoto de magnitud
7,7 sacudió al país las autoridades
sismológicas informaron que el epicentro
del movimiento se registró en el Estado
de Michoacán al menos una persona perdió
la vida por el sismo que se registró en
la fecha en la que se conmemoran los
terremotos de 1985 y 2017 los más
destructivos en la historia reciente del
país
por tercera vez un sismo sacudió a
México un 19 de septiembre el movimiento
telúrico de magnitud 7,7 reavivo los
peores miedos de los ciudadanos que
conmemoraban los mortíferos terremotos
de 1985 y 2017 una hora después de que
las alarmas por el simulacro anual
callaran a las 13:05 hora local comenzó
el temblor la verdad es que momentos
como este son muy difíciles sobre todo
revives la experiencia pasada el último
sismo sobre todo y pues nos metemos en
un angustia Ojalá que el gobierno pueda
realmente entender lo que la ciudadanía
vive en todo momento no en el sismo sino
también antes y posterior al cine es un
aviso más no de la naturaleza para que
hagamos bien las cosas Si bien las
secuelas de este terremoto no han sido
tan letales como los pasados la huella
psicológica Es evidente muchos
ciudadanos tuvieron que ser atendidos
por crisis nerviosas las autoridades
mexicanas reportaron un muerto en un
centro comercial de Manzanillo hasta 16
horas del 19 de septiembre se han
registrado 217
réplicas del sismo de 7,7 ocurrido en
Michoacán en Ciudad de México se emitió
una orden de evacuación obligatoria si
bien no se reportaron daños muchos
lloraban Recordando el terremoto de hace
cinco años que mató a 375 personas y la
coincidencia de las fechas es un día de
luto desde Se declaró desde 1985 y
después en 2017 por eso se hizo la
bandera a media asta
pero no hay Repito científicamente nada
que nos establezca algo sobre el 19 de
septiembre la coordinación Nacional de
Protección Civil de México descartó
activar la alerta de Tsunami sin embargo
advirtió de variaciones anómalas del
nivel del mar de hasta 82 centímetros en
la región donde se originó el sismo
vamos al vecino Estados Unidos porque
las autoridades fronterizas informaron
que por primera vez en la historia se
superaron los dos millones de arrestos
de personas indocumentadas esto en los
últimos 11 meses al tiempo se conoció
que aumentaron considerablemente las
detenciones de migrantes provenientes de
Venezuela Cuba y Nicaragua que cruzan
irregularmente la frontera Sur esto a la
vez que disminuyó la cifra de mexicanos
y de otros países de donde
tradicionalmente parten los migrantes
Cristóbal Vázquez corresponsal de Franz
24 en la capital estadounidense nos
explicó A qué se debe este aumento de
los arrestos en agosto y cómo se
comparan con las cifras de la
Administración anterior
el aumento de arrestos en agosto se debe
en gran parte el aumento general de
migrantes que están llegando no sólo de
Centroamérica sino también de Cuba y
Venezuela según la agencia de aduanas y
protección de fronteras de Estados
Unidos el mes pasado se detuvieron a más
de 55 mil personas que trataron de estar
a Estados Unidos de forma ilegal al
respecto Chris magnus comisionado de
esta agencia dijo en un comunicado que
los regímenes comunistas fallidos en
Venezuela Nicaragua y Cuba están
impulsando precisamente esta Nueva Ola
de migración en todo el hemisferio
occidental incluyendo el reciente
aumento de detenciones en la frontera
suroeste de Estados Unidos otro de los
factores que ha influido en el aumento
de detenciones es que el presidente
byden pues ha mantenido en piel título
42 una medida sanitaria de prevención
contra el que permite a la patrulla
fronteriza de tener y expulsar
inmediatamente a inmigrantes
indocumentados hay que mencionar que
Durante los cuatro años de Trump el
promedio de detenciones era cercano al
medio millón de personas al año según
datos de la patrulla fronteriza cifras
muy inferiores a los dos primeros años
de la administración de baile
una jueza de Baltimore anuló la condena
por asesinato en primer grado contra
atlans acusado en 1999 de haber
asesinado su ex novia después de que los
fiscales y la defensa presentaron
documentos cuestionando la integridad
del juicio y las pruebas tras 23 años de
prisión el caso ganó popularidad en el
año 2014 gracias al podcast cereal que
arrojaba dudas sobre la culpabilidad de
sayette El podcast te fue descargado más
de 340 millones de veces sabías seguirá
vigilado por GPS a la espera de un nuevo
juicio y la fiscalía tiene 30 días para
decidir si retira los cargos jaimin lee
la ex novia del hombre de 41 años fue
estrangulada y enterrada de forma
clandestina en un parque
en esta etapa se ha fijado un juicio se
ha fijado una nueva fecha para el juicio
porque aún no declaramos que adnance es
inocente
pero declaramos que en aras de la
equidad y la justicia tiene derecho a un
nuevo juicio y debido a que este es un
caso en curso hay límites a lo que puedo
decir sobre este asunto
pero es imperativo que Comencemos el
proceso de asegurar un nuevo juicio con
la representación adecuada del señor
sayet para garantizar que la familia de
la señorita jaimin Lee sabe con plena
confianza que la persona responsable de
su muerte tendrá que rendir cuentas
la familia de la señorita lim merece un
cierre merece justicia y tenemos la
intención de luchar por eso
hay alerta en las Islas turcas y caicos
puntualmente en la isla gran turca ante
el fortalecimiento del huracán Fiona que
pasó a categoría 2 y lleva vientos
máximos sostenidos de 170 kilómetros por
hora más temprano el fenómeno tocó suelo
en República Dominicana donde al menos
una persona perdió la vida y se
reportaron cortes eléctricos y daños
materiales obligando a cientos de
personas a evacuar en Puerto Rico la
situación continúa siendo crítica por
los daños a la red eléctrica el
presidente Joe biden prometió el
despliegue de más agentes federales para
enfrentar el impacto del paso del
fenómeno natural Alba Santana nos amplía
con su avance Fiona sigue dejando
devastación a su paso al tocar el suelo
este lunes en República Dominicana el
fenómeno natural derribo árboles y cortó
líneas eléctricas
con una velocidad de traslación de 13
kilómetros por hora y se desplaza hacia
el noroeste de la República Dominicana
con daños materiales en viviendas e
inundaciones que obligaron a evacuar a
cientos de personas en la isla el
gobierno también suspendió la actividad
laboral con alerta roja en la mayoría
del territorio
en Puerto Rico el temporal dejó un
apagón general desde el domingo con
fallos en la electricidad de toda la
isla y también a con cientos de
evacuados después de la advertencia de
los meteorólogos de que los niveles de
agua podrían ser históricos en el país
Entonces estamos orientando a las
personas de parte
y esa que hay que dejarlos
las mascotas
tenemos un refugio
y puede llevar su mascotas allí la gente
Todavía no se ha recuperado del huracán
María de 2017 que dejó miles de muertes
y ahora cinco años después ven como sus
casas vuelven a sufrir daños ahora se
espera que Fiona abandone la isla y tome
más fuerza a medida que avanza hacia el
norte
el cambio climático sigue golpeando a la
amazonía brasileña según la agencia
espacial de este país el número de
incendios registrados en lo que va del
año ya superó la cifra total de los
registrados en 2021 el monitoreo por
satélite muestra que hay registro de
75.592 conflagraciones entre el primero
de enero y el 18 de septiembre Mientras
que el año pasado la cifra total
75.090 los datos aumentan la presión
sobre el presidente Jair bolsonaro quien
Busca la reelección en los comicios de
octubre pero enfrenta fuertes críticas
internacionales por los daños a la
amazonía ocurridos durante su gestión
es todo por el momento en France 24
continúen con nosotros que volvemos en
breve
[Música]